I will not say when we are going to
attack but attack we will they will be
met with fire and fury like the world
has never seen it's almost nine months
into Donald Trump's presidency and I've
got a question specifically for the old
libertarians for Trump crowd how much
more winning can you take to stand up
there was a small but vocal band of
limited government folks who supported
the billionaire real estate mogul on the
ground said he couldn't possibly be as
bad as Hillary Clinton or even most of
the other Republican candidates
especially when it came to foreign
policy I personally have had to put
aside my libertarian beliefs to support
Trump because I think that I won the
debate is because of his inability or
refusal to rank Hillary and Donald
leading the pack was economist Walter
block to beat me in a competitive debate
in New York City right before the
election on whether or not libertarian
should support Donald Trump blocks
argument was that the perfect is the
enemy of the good and the Donald is the
most congruent with the libertarian
perspective especially on foreign policy
but Trump has turned out to be anything
but a non interventionist he promised to
bring fire and fury to North Korea the
likes of which in this world had never
been seen before he bombed Syria on the
same humanitarian grounds he explicitly
denounced during his campaign he
escalated war efforts in Yemen in Iraq
and more recently announced plans to win
in Afghanistan his Secretary of State
declared that the u.s. might not walk
away with a battlefield victory and the
graveyard of Empires but neither would
the Taliban that's not inspirational
it's stupid apart from his foreign
policy follies this anti free trader and
nativist has turned out to be even less
libertarian than advertised during the
campaign they're rapists and some I
assume are good people he's continued
giving mealy-mouthed support to white
supremacist any pardon Joe Arpaio
America's toughest sheriff who is found
in contempt of court after he continued
to illegally racially profile and detain
Latino suspects nobody is higher than me
in Trump's Attorney General Jeff
Sessions is walking back a decade of
incremental progress on criminal justice
reform Trump's the regulatory push is
all to the good
but it's overwhelmed by his other
policies and there's also no question
that at this point Trump is doing
virtually everything he can to Ellen
eight libertarians who believe in
shrinking the size scope and spending of
governments the excuse that Hillary
Clinton would have been worse is getting
older than Bernie Sanders the perfect is
the enemy of the good but what the
president has shown us so far just isn't
good enough
[Music]
you